and now we go live to the president of
the united states
donald j trump on the telephone mr
president thank you very much for being
here
good morning thank you i want to start
with breaking news and that is the note
that you have
revealed from your doctor which says you
are no longer considered a transmission
risk does this suggest you no longer
have kovitz sir
yes and not only that it seems like i'm
immune
so i can go way out of a basement which
i would have done anyway in which i did
because you have to run a country you
have to get out of the basement and
it looks like i'm immune for i don't
know maybe a long time or maybe
a short time it could be a lifetime
nobody really knows but i'm immune so
so the president is in very good shape
to fight the battle mr president i want
you to i want you to answer your critics
because your critics
are uh going uh really uh betting upset
about your event at the white house
yesterday
about your rally that you're planning
tomorrow they say it is still too soon
for you to be around people and to be
going out
that you could still spread covid what
are you
doing in terms of ensuring that everyone
will be safe
at your rally in florida this week
tomorrow
well the doctors the white house doctors
as you know are the best
and they said totally free of
spreading there's no spread and it
wasn't yesterday either
and by the way i don't know if you
noticed i was on a balcony the closest
person was probably a couple of hundred
feet away
and they were down and on grass there
was nobody even close to me yesterday
but even yesterday i knew i was uh free
i beat this
crazy horrible china virus and
it also gives you immunity i mean it
does give you immunity even the uh
the people that just cannot accept
anything i mean they just don't want to
accept anything no so
uh we i passed the highest test the
highest standards
and i'm in great shape and i have to
tell you i feel fantastically i really
feel good and
i even feel good by the fact that you
know the word immunity means something
having
uh having uh really a protective
glow means something i think it's very
important to have that
to have that is a very important thing
mr president you have been criticized
for your handling of covid19 i want to
take
you back to when we first learned of
covet 19
and uh on january 16th uh the senate was
uh holding an impeachment trial
of you this uh trial ended uh on
february 5th
where you were acquitted did anyone
mention kovid to you
during that time because you stopped all
travel from china
on january 31st which obviously in
retrospect was a very good move
but your your colleagues in the senate
nancy pelosi in the house and her
colleagues are saying that you did not
handle covid correctly
while they were actually trying to
impeach you did
the covet conversation come up at all
during the impeachment trial or around
that date
no because we were focused on
impeachment it was a fake impeachment it
turned out to be
and in fact if you look at the house
where we had 197 to nothing votes we
even got
a democrat or two uh voting for us
it was a disgrace it was a total
disgrace no it wasn't
discussed what was discussed was nancy
pelosi and others saying that
keep the country uh don't don't ban
chyna don't do that in fact
she was dancing on the streets of
chinatown in
san francisco and the reason she was
because she wanted the business to come
in she didn't want to close
up the country and that was a long time
after i had already closed it had i not
dr fauci said i saved thousands
tens of thousands of lives by acting
that early and
there were not a lot of people that
agreed with me when i wanted to close it
and
it was very interesting but the
prediction was 2.2 million people were
going to die
so we're over 200 000 and one is too
many i always say it one is too many
should have never happened
it's china's fault but one is too many
but
2.2 million was the prediction as to how
many people would die
we lost 200 000 plus
and uh you know there are those that say
we did a phenomenal job
we did a phenomenal job and if you look
at
all over the world our mortality rate
our mortality rate is good and our
recovery rate by the way as an economy
is the number one in the world we
recovered faster
and went down less than any other place
but our recovery rate is the best in the
world maria
mr president i want to ask you about a
policy in a second term but first i've
got to get your reaction to what nancy
pelosi said this weekend
she is questioning if those steroid
treatments that you were on i know
you're not on them anymore
are influencing your decision making and
on friday she raised the idea
of a presidential succession bill to
alter the 25th amendment
process she wants congress to be able to
take out a president if they deem he is
unfit here's nancy pelosi this weekend i
got to get your reaction listen to this
the 25th amendment creates a path per
serving
stability if a president suffers a
crippling physical or mental problem and
is
on quote in the amendment unable
to discharge the powers and duties of
his office
and transfers his powers specifically
section four
of the amendment empowers congress to
set up an independent
body to confront such a crisis
mr president your reaction well i think
she's talking about joe biden
because to be honest with you he's the
one that's got the problem and obviously
it's obvious to anybody that watches him
speak
he's the one that got that has the
problem and they want to put a
super radical left person in like kamala
who's worse than
who's further left than bernie sanders
and you know that whole thing is
breaking up now because
the left isn't getting what they want
all of a sudden they're back into
fracking and all the things that they
talked about they wouldn't do and now
they're saying they're going to do them
and
the left is very unhappy i'm going to
get a lot of people because of my great
policies on trade they're going to just
like last time bernie sanders people are
going to vote for me because of what
i've done on trade
because what i've done in trade is a
miracle and
and we have a long way to go uh because
frankly they interrupted it with the
impeachment hoax and various other
things
but no i think she's talking and a lot
of people think that she's talking about
uh joe biden getting him out and now
frankly uh you know that's that's the
way i view it i certainly view it that
way
as far as medication i'm not on any
medication i'm not on any medication
and the medications that i took were
standard pretty much
routine uh other than the one which is a
miracle it's
the antibody stuff which is incredible
how it works
and we're going to be delivering that to
hospitals we're waiting for the
emergency use authorization
and we're going to be delivering that to
hospitals all over the country to take
care and
ultimately all over the world because
it's it's incredible
actually what we have done maria
during this short period of time six
seven months
in terms of labs and doctors and
medicines and
uh therapeutics and not even talking
about vaccines which are going to be
phenomenal and
coming out very soon what we've done
nobody else could have done
and i got the fda to approve things at
levels of speed
that nobody would have thought possible
could have taken years and i got them to
do it in weeks
and they did the right thing by the way
but you'll see that very soon with the
vaccines and you'll also see it with the
antibodies the antibodies have been
fantastic
so when do you think regeneron gets the
emergency use
authorization what's the timing on that
i hope very soon and eli lilly makes a
similar
product a similar drug and i hope it's
going to be very soon
because i can tell you that it it was
great now i think i would have done well
anyway i think you know i hope
but you know who wants to take a chance
as the expression goes
but the antibody kind of thing that i
took
was i felt i felt really good
almost after taking it and what that
does is it gives people in hospitals as
one of the scientists said to me we'll
clean out the hospitals we'll get
everybody out of the hospitals
this is really i know people call it a
therapeutic
but to me it's a cure okay to me it's a
cure
i think it's much more than a
therapeutic and i want to get it
immediately into the hospitals
and i want to it's a transfusion it
takes one hour
and it transfuses into the body
and i'll tell you what what a difference
it is and again i think i would have
been fine
you know i mean i'm in good health
i think i would have been fine and
people have to realize that and
once you once you do recover you're
immune so now you have a president
who doesn't have to hide in a basement
like his opponent
uh you have a president who is immune
which is a big
i think which is a very important thing
frankly
mr president i have reported on fox
business before
that my medical sources have told me
that joe biden had
two brain aneurysms not one but two
brain aneurysms i pray to god it's not
true but
my medical sources are solid on this
that he has had two brain aneurysms i
hope he's okay
do you believe that he should be
disclosing that
and are you willing to commit to telling
us any issues that may have been
in the past for you if he comes clean
and tells us
exactly what is the issue in terms of
any
mental uh issues that we need to know
about
for example these two brain aneurysms
that i have reported on in the past
well i have no issues i mean you know in
all fairness you've known me for a long
time
and i have had no issues medically and
this was the first issue and this is
artificially induced
by china but i have no issues yeah he
should
certainly come clean and he should he
should say something about that
absolutely
if that's the case kevin mccarthy kevin
mccarthy said that he's seeking a way to
test nancy pelosi's fitness
as well in terms of her own mental state
i saw your tweet that she was actually
targeting
joe biden but she is third in line for
the presidency and she did say
that she's raising the possibility of
becoming
acting president in the event of a
contested election
your reaction i don't think she could
pass basic aptitude tests
personally i really don't i don't
believe it and speaking about joe biden
uh if you look at joe he was coughing
yesterday horribly and grabbing his mask
as he's coughing and speaking and
grabbing his mask and coughing
and i don't know what that was all about
and it didn't get much press because the
press doesn't do that but he was
coughing yesterday
quite badly i must tell you and it was
not a good thing to watch and and
as he's coughing he's grabbing his mask
with his fingers
so you may want to look into that too mr
president let's turn to policy i'd like
to
ensure that the american people
understand your policy proposals
should you have a second term i want to
talk about taxes
economy health care give us your
proposals your plans
to get the economy back to where it was
before covet arrived when we had a three
and a half percent unemployment
rate back in february what do you want
to do in terms of your policies in a
second term sir
well the first thing we have to do marie
is open up our country you can't keep
all these states closed up the democrat
states and they're not doing well
and the country is doing well we're
looking like a super v
but you know despite the fact new york
has to open up new york's like a ghost
town new york is very sad what's going
on there and
and other places we just want a case in
michigan
against the governor the governor that
is you know the i call the complainer in
chief
all she does is complain except when
she's on the phone directly
all she does is say thank you very much
for doing such a great job
but the fact is that you have to open up
wisconsin you have to open up north
carolina
and pennsylvania we want another case
there about opening it up
because it's unconstitutional what these
people are doing
so number one you have to open up you
got to get the kids back in school
and if you look at 99.9 percent with
children i mean they're very their
immune systems are very strong
and uh we have to get the schools open
we have to get the place open
these people are doing it and by the way
after the election about
two minutes after the election they'll
announce that they're opening they they
know what they're
doing look they know what they're doing
and and it's it's a disgrace
uh but i think and the other thing is i
don't know if you've seen but we're
doing very well
we're up in miami we're up in arizona
we're up in
many many states more than we were
last time and i think we're doing very
well
well i just want to say governor cuomo's
office called me
to say that they are not looking at
locking anything down until
the election in fact he said that there
are two areas with spikes in new york
that are on pause that's in queens and
brooklyn two-week period went into
effect
uh past thursday october 8th and they
will remain that way for two weeks so
they're doing it on a rolling basis in
order to see
when things can open up but new york
obviously
has been in bad shape a lot of
restaurants are going to go under
the economy there is struggling and
that's one of the issues in terms of
this stimulus
where are we on the stimulus talks will
you give money to places like new york
will the government give money to places
like new york will you agree to that
well republicans want to do it we're
having a hard time with nancy pelosi she
thinks she can influence the election
and i think they're hurting themselves
by not doing it but the republicans want
to do it we want to do
stimulus we want to help the airlines
again because the airline's always a
tough business
we want to help the restaurants hotels
we want to help
businesses that really it's not it's not
their fault it's china's fault and we
want to help
maria and and frankly uh
you know we're ready to go we're all
ready to go we can't get nancy pelosi to
sign the document
let me move on to the policies
differences because i want you to know
and i want our audience to know
we have invited myself and my team have
invited
vice president joe biden as well as vice
presidential
candidate kamala harris on this program
many times
so far they have said no we're
unavailable
yeah they won't they won't go on your
show because you'll ask them questions i
watched that
town hall that nbc gave them gave him
the other night
that was like for a child they were
asking
questions that you would ask a child a
young child
and i've never seen anything like it but
i've watched this
process where he has the uh questions
and then he reads an answer from a
reporter a legitimate reporter or
not anymore in my opinion legitimate but
i watched where they
give him the questions and they he reads
the answer from a computer
nobody's ever seen anything like this in
history before what's going on
it's a real disgrace and then you look
at this guy scully he turned out to be a
fraud
you look at scully he was a never
trumper and uh
you know you look at what and then he
said he was hacked that's always you
know anthony weiner said he was hacked
too
they all say they were hacked every time
something happens where they did
something
and got caught the first thing they do
is they say oh we were hacked oh we were
hacked well
he wasn't hacked he knows that he's
ashamed it's a shame
and i hear that c-span is very upset
with what happened
but uh scully you know he was going to
be and chris wallace was a disaster
of course wallace went out and went out
and just kept saving biden every time
you'd ask a question
chris wallace would save biden you know
i understand chris for a long time i
liked his father's father was great
his father you know chris wallace chris
wallace chris wallace tried to do a good
job
uh at the debate let me move on to
policy sir
well uh joe biden wants to raise taxes
by four trillion dollars mr president he
wants to take the corporate tax rate
back up to 28 percent
he wants to take capital gains taxes
back up to 39.6
but he says he's only going to raise
taxes on anybody making 400 000
or more but while saying that he also
says he's going to completely reverse
your tax cut plan that's right now your
tax cut plan lowered taxes for all
income levels so if he's going to
reverse it that means all
income levels are going to see tax
increases is that politics is that a lie
that he's saying it's 400 000 well
everything he says is a lie and he gets
away with it no republican
especially me but no republican can get
away with what he does
if he terminates and he said he's going
to terminate my tax cuts well
that means 2 000 plus plus plus
and that doesn't even include the
thousand dollar child tax credit
that everybody gets so you're talking
about 2 000 plus child tax credit
plus many other things and then if he
goes with his energy policy where he
wants to end
he's going to end fracking you know that
he's going to end petroleum products
even though that'll put us at a
tremendous disadvantage
not even disadvantaged we wouldn't be
able to compete with the world
but he's going to end that so now
instead of two dollar gasoline you're
gonna be paying six dollar gasoline
he wants to take cars away from people
the whole thing is is
insane okay it's insane so how can the
auto industry vote for a guy that wants
to take your cars away
and he literally wants to take your cars
away i mean the whole thing is
what he is saying is crazy now he gets
away with it because he can say whatever
he wants
he said for a year there would be no
fracking
and and you heard that many times where
he couldn't say it any stronger
then all of a sudden he said there's
going to be fracking as soon as he gets
the nomination there's going to be
fracking
but you know he doesn't mean that
because he doesn't control it he's weak
and he doesn't control it his party
controls him the killers of his party
control him
he agreed to the manifesto with bernie
sanders aoc and all of these people
he agreed to it if you ever read that
manifesto
our country goes out of business we
become venezuela no we become venezuelan
but he agreed to everything in there
but when he's on television he doesn't
say that now
in pennsylvania if you stop fracking you
won't have a pennsylvania
texas oklahoma north dakota many many
states
ohio you have to frack you have to frack
and if they don't frack energy's going
to go through the roof and you're going
to lose millions and millions of jobs
well this guy all of a sudden the minute
he gets he goes he says no will frack
now you know put a little caveat on it
but the fact is
i've never seen such lying as this and
they don't even question him they don't
even call him out
it's incredible actually mr president
but pennsylvania i want to get through
yep pennsylvania marie can't vote for
him because they'd be out of business
texas he's against guns he's against god
and he's against oil yep and then i hear
texas a bit
we're winning texas by a lot i think
we're winning everything by a lot you
want to know the truth maria
uh i want to i want to go through this
policy uh differences and then i've got
to get to the declassifications as well
so
let me move on taxes uh speak to voters
right now mr president
what do you want to do with taxes
particularly the middle class and then
give us your health care plan
because the the kamala harris at the
debate
said that the gop's push to end
obamacare means quote they're coming for
you
uh they are criticizing you saying that
you have no plan for
pre-existing conditions so what's your
response in terms of speaking to voters
on taxes
and on health care sir well first of all
in pre-existing conditions they know
that's false
the obamacare we have run it really well
we got rid of the individual mandate
which was the key to obamacare but the
most unpopular thing where you pay a lot
of money for the privilege of not having
good health care
for and just a disaster i got rid of it
that was a big thing that changed
obamacare that really didn't even make
it obamacare
but it's still no good and we managed it
much better than them remember with a
five billion dollar server
we manage it much to the website we
manage it much better than them
but obamacare is no good we are going to
have new health care
we are going to protect people with
pre-existing conditions
and they're going to pay a lot less
money for the new health care now we've
already been doing that
through different plans through
department of labor etc etc we've
already been doing it
we have some great plans but what they
want to do is get rid of 180 million
people who have great private health
care that they
love and they want to take it away and
go socialize medicine
it's going to be a disaster as far as
taxes we gave the largest tax cut in the
history of our
country and a big beneficiary we're
middle income people
we're giving a middle income tax cut
very soon as soon as we
win we're giving a middle income tax cut
it'll be a very substantial middle
income tax cut
and i've already done this but you have
to understand we're increasing it
but if you look he wants to end the
trump tax cut as we discussed
but if you do that you're talking about
two thousand dollars
child tax credit but very importantly
you're not mentioning one thing
energy uh energy will be two to three
thousand dollars more a family and
probably much more than that
if they go with their crazy green new
deal because their green new deal
is crazy and it won't let us compete
with the rest of the world
we will not be we will be we will be
venezuela large version that's what will
end up being if they
if they even think about some of the
things that they have in the green new
deal
and it was made up by people that don't
even have knowledge they don't even have
knowledge they have no idea
what they're doing wall street analysts
have told me they believe
elizabeth warren will be one of the most
influential voices in abiding
administration on economic policy
she has been very clear about her wealth
taxed whatever wealth you have will be
added up
your entire life and you'll get taxed on
this but many people feel the most
important concern going into this
election sir is
do you have a reliable plan to prevent
the massive
voter fraud that may be attempted we
have a list here of what we've been
seeing
across the country one hundred 000
ballots
thrown away in one area another 50 000
ballots thrown away
uh elsewhere we've got the list that
we're going to come up with this graphic
right now
what are you going to do in terms of
ballot fraud
uh and uh you know lying in terms of uh
ballots being inaccurate 100 000 voters
in brooklyn
new york received ballots with the wrong
name and address 50 000 voters in ohio
received incorrect
absentee ballots 2 000 plus in los
angeles county
this has all happened sir just in the
last few weeks
that's right and it's happened over the
last year too and all you have to do is
go back to the democrat primary and take
a look at iowa
what happened there they still don't
know who won it's a disaster the whole
thing is a disaster but before you talk
about that elizabeth warren
she ran the credit union she ran
different things she's been
horrible to people horrible horrible to
people
and what's going to happen if something
like that does happen
all of these companies that have moved
into the united states and invested in
the united states
we brought in billions and billions of
dollars coming in
they're all going to be leaving they're
all going to be leaving and they're
going to take them with them their jobs
and their money and their taxes
it's all going to be leaving we brought
in car
companies and institutions and
manufacturing which as you remember
president obama said was dead you'd need
a magic wand to start it up i created
700 000 manufacturing jobs
all of that stuff will as fast as it
came in it'll leave
if you start raising taxes on them and
it's a very simple formula you know the
world is a
pretty big place and very flexible and
these people don't care
so much like they should perhaps about
our country as much as other things
they want to be able to go where they
can do the best for their shareholders
or themselves
they will be leaving our country just as
fast as they came in
and we've never had a better time than
last year
and the in the coming year will be even
better because if you see the way it's
building better than anybody
the coming year will be even better as
far as the ballots
are concerned what i did i've been
telling you this for
a year and a half because i've been
watching local elections like i've
watched the carolyn maloney disaster in
new york
a small congressional election they have
no idea where the ballots are
it was fraud they're missing but look at
all of the instances that have taken
place over the last two or three weeks
you don't have to go back look at what's
going on
do you have a plan to make sure this
doesn't happen well first of all we've
been winning cases we've been winning a
lot of cases which have been reported
where they don't even want the election
to be determined on november 3rd they
want the election maria to be determined
uh two weeks after the vote comes in
it's the craziest thing so we won't even
know
but we've been winning those cases
judges federal judges have been ruling
nope they have to be in by a certain
time we've won a lot of cases that
have not been reported but very
importantly i've been saying this is
going to happen
they're trying to steal the election the
good news is
law enforcement is watching very
strongly
nevada and many other states
pennsylvania
in all cases where you have uh where you
have
democrat governors i mean democrat
control
north carolina we're watching it very
closely and the people are watching it
very closely and by the way
the votes coming in right now look very
very promising for republicans because
republicans are going out to vote
they don't want to do the ballot thing
because they don't trust it republicans
are going out to vote
and those polls that are open and will
be opening up
they're going to be swamped all right
let me get you a few more things before
we go mr president uh we just heard from
rick grinnell on the media company
social media companies are you going to
push
to remove the liability protection that
social media enjoys right now that they
can't get sued
so section 230 a lot of us are looking
at it it's a disgrace what's happening
it's a disgrace
it's called section 230. uh yeah a lot
of people are looking at it i can't say
yet what we're doing i can tell you this
it's very unfair what they do
very unfair it's rigging an election in
a different form than the ballots
but it's rigging an election and it's
unfair so a lot of people are looking at
section 230 yes
me too on to the declassifications that
we heard from dni john ratcliffe we've
discussed so much
about the plan the plot to take you down
we now know it was hillary's idea
the fbi knew that there was no collusion
but they kept going forward
uh spying on your campaign and your
presidency
when do you believe the fbi started
working hand in glove with the clinton
operation
to take you down was it early 16 or do
you think it started even in 2015
it started before i won and it started
when they started seeing that i could
win and it's a disgrace and we caught
them
we caught them spying on our campaign we
caught we caught them doing things
look they were trying to destroy an
administration
and they didn't do it because this
administration has done more than
any administration in its first three
and a half years in the history of our
country
that we have done an incredible job
whether it's the military or the tax
cuts or the regulation cuts
or the economy nobody's done a job like
we've done despite
what they've done we caught them and we
caught them called maria
and it's a beautiful thing now we have
to do something about it
well that's what i'm saying i mean you
could you know you authorize the
declassification of these documents
but what does that do if we don't have
john durham and bill barr following up
can you demand that they release this
people are still sitting on documents
yeah i hope they're going to and i will
say this
documents are being released at a level
now that nobody's ever seen before
things that nobody thought were going to
get released have been released and
you're seeing it you're seeing it all
the time you're seeing what's going on
we caught them cold we have them cold
and now they have to do something about
it but but other documents are going to
be released
maria which are breathtaking where do
you see what's coming
really breathtaking is is it about
hillary clinton or is it about
the the fbi that's coming out everything
it's about everything
hillary clinton is uh crooked hillary i
don't call it crooked hillary for
nothing
and you know just the one thing i keep
going back to it she got a subpoena
from the united states congress right
got a subpoena
how do you how do you uh how do you get
rid of your emails after you get a
subpoena she got texts for text messages
emails etc
how do you do that it's criminal what
she did is criminal well you
okay you told me you told me for my book
when we did the interview for my book
that there are people in government that
are just protected
i guess she's protected well they're
trying like hell but we got them
we look we have found things that
that nobody can believe nobody can
believe what we found
and and i'll tell you what the level the
level at which we found them
people are shocked they're stunned and
let's see what happens
but hillary president was hillary
clinton was totally
crooked and so we're part of it i've got
to ask you this final question
mr president i want to end i want to end
on a lighter note
a mysterious subject if you will uh can
you explain
why the department of defense has set up
a ufo
tax force here's what i've got from the
guardian the u.s department of defense
has formed a new body to investigate
what it calls unidentified aerial
phenomena
to monitor reported sightings of what
most people call ufos
mr president as we wrap up here are
there ufos
well i'm gonna have to check on that i
mean i've heard that i heard that two
days ago so i'll check on that i'll take
a good strong look at that but
i will tell you this uh we now have
created
a military the likes of which we've
never had before in terms of equipment
the the equipment that we have the
weapons that we have
and hopefully hope to god we never have
to use them but we have created
a military the likes of which nobody has
nobody has ever had russia china
they're all envious of what we've had
all built in the usa we've rebuilt it
2.5 trillion dollars
as far as the other question i'll check
on it i heard i heard about it two days
ago
actually that is fascinating uh by the
way
do you believe russia and china were
spying and
knowing our secrets because of hillary's
unsecured server real quick we've got
20 seconds well i think she was uh out
there with classified information she
was giving it to anybody it was on
anthony weiner's laptop
and the fbi did nothing about it and the
fbi looked the greatest people in the
world are in the fbi but the top people
were
scum absolute scum and they did a
horrible job for our country
mr president we so appreciate your time
this morning thank you very much sir